cimetière dégagé
cette semaine avoir parlé d'un gadget
d'une technologie que je connais quand
même assez bien pour des raisons
familiales
les radioamateurs peu fâché vous envoyer
sur le cimetière mais je trouve que ben
comme vous allez l'entendre et en partie
aussi me tiens on va parler peut-être de
zombies ok femmes hommes et qui est
encore vivant évidemment ce pour faire
image mais pourquoi vous connaissez bien
ça parce que papa est traduit en matière
alors mon père c'est télégraphiste dans
la marine 2
mais la montre et il y là il a été admis
aux amateurs il faisait surtout jaser
avec avec ses copains vit déjà à boston
depuis toujours qu'ils connaissaient
mais je me souviens de sela d'appels
vers 2 ct et c'est comme ça qu'ils se
connaissent et je pense qu'ils
s'appellent alors oui je vous raconte
une histoire vaut la peine car mon père
est décédé il ya un de ses amis qui est
venu au salon funéraire et nous on a
toujours connu par ses dettes d'appel
s'invite à 2 g f
alors si si nous écoutent ce support ce
qui est encore dans mais si nous
écoutent devrait savoir que jamais
envoyé la fille carte de remerciement
parce que on le connaissait on n'est
jamais sûr d'un stade j phi phi est
signée de gisozi mais vous voyez ça me
surprend pas parce que c'était un réseau
social dans la verte tout à fait ça et
c'est patent donc un gadget qu'un mode
de communication qui est sur le déclin
pour vous dire il ya 15000 détenteurs de
licences au québec y en a environ 3500
qui sont actives sur l'ensemble des
populations de jeu beaucoup plus que je
sais ça exactement il ya ces fonctions
la radio de réseau social qui ont été
remplacés par d'autres plus pratique on
ne même plus besoin de présenter
aujourd'hui mais bon vous allez
l'entendre les radioamateurs et elles
attirent moins l'attention mais elles
conservent néanmoins leur pertinence
j'ai parlé avec guy lamoureux qui pdg de
l'association provinciale des radios
amateurs du québec on écoute de ricco
avait de l gl
bien sûr ça va très bien j'ai dit est ce
que tu es tu allé à l'extérieur ce matin
voir les belles couleurs d'automne
personnellement je suis arrivé les
radioamateurs officiellement avec mon
indicatif d'appel en 1989
mais je connaissais des radioamateurs
depuis 1959 alors que j'avais 12 ans à
peu près et avec mon père on était allé
dans un field et qu'on appelle c'est une
fin de semaine où les radioamateurs se
réunissaient dans la nature sans sur sa
d'alimentation électrique au que des
génératrices ou des choses pour
pratiquer les communications situations
d'urgence de tous les temps les
radioamateurs ont été en première ligne
lors de catastrophes
on a un protocole d'entente avec la
sécurité civile de la province de québec
qui fait en sorte que dans l'eau mais et
si un système de relais pour les
communications en situation d'urgence
lors du verglas par exemple les
radioamateurs ont été positionnés à la
demande du gouvernement à différents
endroits pour faire les communications
qui était inexistante les cellulaires ne
pouvait plus être rechargé les batteries
alors nous étions les seuls qui par
exemple entre un hôpital et des
compagnies pharmaceutiques l'hôpital
pouvait te même pas assez pour des
urgences des commandes de produits pour
être approvisionnés en produits
pharmaceutiques c c'est des choses qui
arrivent et de lg est là les côtes
qu'est ce qui lui fait encore rémy la
radio amateur c'est l'inconnu tantôt
j'ai eu des communications sur la radio
avec une personne quelqu'un qui a fait
un appel pour parler un autre duo matin
je lui ai parlé
on en retire des bénéfices dès juin vous
percevez dans la voix humaine des choses
que vous ne percevez pas qu'un vous êtes
dit courriel quand vous faites des
textos
on a été partie prenante à l'évolution
technologique
avant même l'arrivée des ordinateurs on
avait notre système de communication ça
s'appelait du paquet
c'est le protocole qu'on utilise pour
les courriels
donc on a été pris que ça dans
différents domaines
c'est sûr que avec les jeunes avec
l'évolution technologique 6 sur
l'internet a pris plus de place c'est
sûr que l'internet
or peut-être un impact sur beaucoup de
jeunes qui auraient été tentés ya 20 30
ans devenu vers la radio amateur qui ne
viennent plus seulement on est dans une
phase de ralentissement
hypo dit que dans cinquante ans que les
radios mais tranchera pas disparu mais
ça fait partie de l'évolution via de lgl
fermeture des lieux
et j'avais quelque chose qui me dit que
il ya trop de bonheur pour envoyer la
radio amateur au cimetière ben c'est
toujours risqué d'annoncer la fin d'un
mode de communication vous le savez il
ya des expériences qui sont menées en ce
moment par des radioamateurs ici même au
québec pour utiliser les lasers pour
justement faire de la communication ça
pourrait déboucher sur des nouvelles
technologies mais moi je me pose une
question quand on entendait dans le
reportage lui a été initié ou à la radio
amateur par son père votre père était
loin donc lui-même un radio amateur
moi j'ai pas été nommé un radio amateur
dans ma vie mais je joue et quand sur
cessé d'en faire j'avais son récepteur
dans ma chambre et ça moi et moi je
mange ses rues pour faire de la radio
ondes courtes j'écoutais en pleine
guerre froide radio moscou des machins
comme ça peut-être que mon intérêt the
way merci monsieur